how do you judge a great leader based on
measurable data
how do you judge a great leader on
immeasurable
data it's not data but imaginable
characteristics so give me measurable
data
okay
simplified guys you guys are actually
making this very complicated
let me tell you measurable measurable
listen
if people around you are making money
and their life is getting better this
year then last year than the year before
is measurable
you're a great leader
if your mds are constantly broke
they can love you they can love to be
around you you can be the sweetest human
being in the world
you can be the greatest speaker you if
your people are not making more money
and their life is not advancing that is
measurable i don't care if you got 95
other things
if you guys are making money
they're eventually not going to be with
you no matter how amazing of a human
being you think you are
i have one job
when jose's in the car outside
and i look at him he's in his car
sebring and i said jose what's up jose's
got that smile on his face he never
shows weakness i said that's not a
normal smile what's up what you got he's
just smiling he's like i'm good man i'm
good
wha what's up why what's up what's going
on i'm good pat i'm good i said what's
up and then boom breaks down crying
one month into php two months we don't
have a product to sell i said jose
what's up
what's up pat i don't have money to pay
for gas bro
and in my mind i'm like get the hell out
in my mind like what are you doing to
these people
this guy will freaking follow you
anywhere what are you doing
give him a hundred bucks
but the hundred bucks saying nothing
i walk away say i'm gonna make this
guy's a freaking millionaire
this guy's freaking got my back i'm
gonna make you a millionaire i'm gonna
do whatever i can for the world to know
who you are
i'm gonna do whatever you're loyal to me
watch what i'm gonna do to you
that's how i see it can you imagine if
jose said i freaking love patty you're
so amazing let's play cards together 10
years into it he's still broke kind of a
freaking leader am i
how do you want me to judge myself i'm
great how often do i have to tell myself
i'm great people have to win around you
i don't care how long do i have with him
do you not think eventually his wife
marlene's gonna say hey let's go find a
better leader that helps you make more
money
at the end of the day she's gonna be
thinking about luke and preston
if i'm sitting here not doing anything
to help advance his life why is he still
around me
he can quit and we can still be friends
but if you're going to be in business
with me i have to help his life advance
i owe it to him not the other way around
some of you guys are too worried about
finding flag carriers for you i'm not
trying to get you to be my flat carrier
i'm your flat carrier the mindset of
flag curies the other way around
not this whole thing of you owe me you
don't owe me
you understand what i'm saying i don't
go with that mindset i owe you i'm on
the cuff for two and a half hours with
richard watch that one night
richard chose to come to php
i'm gonna do my part to see his dreams
become a reality he's got to do his part
i don't take it as hey you know if you
don't like i'm gonna be crying and i'm
like oh my god it's all my fault i feel
so guilty i'm not saying no but i'm
gonna do my part bro you want to be in
it i got your back let's go
but i want to see his life changing
when marvin and d come here i'm gonna do
my part what do you need i'm gonna do my
part
money you're going to make the most
money you've ever made in this industry
you're going to make it with us i don't
care where you've been you can make the
most money here because i'm going to do
the part for you
you become flag carrier to them not the
other way around this there's this whole
notion about everybody has to be your
flag carrier
you wonder some people have flag tears
because that they're they're flag
carriers i don't wake up in the morning
saying how can i make you my flag carry
i don't think that way
i think that's gonna be yours
when i sit down late at night in the car
with these guys and i'm talking she's in
tears we're having a great conversation
i'm gonna say i can't wait for your
freaking wildest dreams to become a
reality i can't wait to see your face
when i see erica's face when she walked
into the closet of this 30 million
dollar house and she's giggling like a
six-year-old girl like my daughter
fires me up when i see that
when i see her sitting on a 15 million
yacht in front of the house from
scarface with michelle pfeiffer coming
down and she's just chilling out there
like this is going to be my life one day
and ricky's standing like a champion
that's what i like
i'm your flat carrier not the other way
around
to me leadership is a different
perspective guys
you can sit there and try to convince
yourself how great of a job you've done
i can sit there and tell myself how
amazing i am for years i'm in a business
six seven years palaio's giving
everything here he's coming in yes he's
difficult but he's still the first code
number i told him polite when he wanted
to quit i'm in colombia he calls me i've
lost my voice for six months did surgery
day after my surgery i can't speak we
lost one md i'm on the phone with grad
sandy for two hours i don't know if you
remember that when i lost my voice two
hours a month jen's like you can't talk
to anybody i just came out of surgery
two hours i'm on the phone with him he
chose to come to phb on his flat carrier
i'm his flat carrier i'm his flag
carrier i'm your flat carrier not the
other way around
the mentality the world will follow you
to the end if you become their flag
carrier i don't wake up in the morning
thinking you owe me anything
i wake up in the morning sam i'm going
to pour so much into you that if you
choose to give it back it's on you but
i'm willing to bank on enough people are
gonna say this freaking guy
this freaking guy
watch what i'm gonna do to this freaking
guy that's my mentality
so then yes
some of you may say well to me a great
leader somebody that doesn't curse then
i don't qualify for being a great leader
every once in a while like curse you may
say a great leader is somebody that
doesn't poke well then i'm not qualified
because i just poked around i called her
brick
pember
what did what i call him i don't
remember didn't it
big cell terrace
we had one other nickname what was the
other nick there was three nicknames
marquee
marquis suazo
timbers uh suazo's and terrace are part
of the lead club they're the only ones
that got three nicknames tonight right
somebody may say well that's not the
christian thing to do well i'm not the
right leader in your world because to
you currency is you shouldn't poke
people i'm disqualified in your world of
being a great leader and i'm okay with
that
i'm okay with that because to you
your currency is stuff that makes you
feel special now i don't judge it that
way
i don't judge it that way i judge it
with
my kids have a simple philosophy what do
you think i want my kids to do when they
grow up what do you think i want my kids
to do when they grow up
what do you think i want them to do what
do you think i want them to do
i could care less what they do
i'm going to be their flag carrier
dude what do you want to do bro just
tell me tell me what you want to do i am
your number one flipping
flag carry for as long as i live a long
time you got a fly carry here bro
guy says pal
all these messages you should want for
office you should go be a president for
the freaking 50 000 time i can't be a
president but watch how many governors
senator congressman and presidents we're
going to put out there just watch watch
how many we're going to put out there
i've said this for 12 years people
thought i was crazy i'm still saying it
today watch how many we will
i don't have to i'm a flag i'm a natural
flag carrier i'm your flat carrier
so how does that change your mindset by
the way
how do you look at leadership now
slightly different ain't it
is it about how many people want to run
through the wall for you no
it's about do they go to sleep saying
this freaking guy will do man
how the hell am i ever going to find a
guy like this man he pisses me off i'm
never going to find a guy like this
that's how you win people
but people around you if they continue
to not make money you are fooling
yourself
and the leaders bulletin is telling you
you're fooling yourself
he wins
he doesn't call me anymore he only calls
me when he needs me that's how it's
supposed to be
what do you need
you ever have a hard time getting a hold
of me have you ever had a hard time
getting a hold of me i'm your flat
carrier why would you have a hard time
getting a hold of me
not the other way around
you're going to get a hold of me if i'm
your guy
you're doing your part like this ceca's
i had a great conversation with sikas up
here i'm excited about them hire him
hyrum is my kind of guy if i was in the
army hirement would be best friends it's
my kind of a guy that's how i judge him
if i was on a football team together
hiram's my guy he's a freaking man's man
and he's still a humble chill guy to be
around
yeah i want to see that guy win
of course i want to see that guy win
we're in ohika castle it's two o'clock
in the morning i'm having a cigar with
pember we're sitting who was with us
that night we're having cigars
dude who was who was with us that night
i freaking fell in love with lou
my man freaking love this guy
that's the mindset of leadership
too often we think like what people can
do for us bro give me a freaking break
i don't think of it that way
i'm gonna get you the director i'm gonna
get you to md you're gonna get a watch
but here's the thing if you don't
appreciate what i do for you
i totally respect it
i am not upset at you bro
you're telling me i don't appreciate
your time i'm not gonna judge you
let me go find 5 10 15 20 other people
once you do i'm still here i'm not going
away
still here but i'm going to go over here
until you can appreciate my relationship
maybe i gotta improve i don't know but i
put it here
by the way let me give you the flip side
i don't feel guilty
it's not like oh my gosh they don't like
me i don't fly that way that's not me
you understand what i'm saying like i'm
very comfortable calling you guys out i
don't lose sleep at all calling you guys
out i like at all
i'm good because i know the intentions
are in the right place
so the next time you so let me ask you a
question now let's flip it on you
internally create a score
don't tell it to anybody
you versus you if if we judge
a great leader
by how many people around them are
winning
and by how many people your flag carrier
to what's your don't answer it what's
your score zero to ten what kind of a
leader are you
because for the first 10 years of my
career was the other way around that's
not leadership
i'm 30 years old it's like hey you know
what about this no no no it's not
leadership bro it's not how life works
one day i woke up
and i said okay
you could be one thing what is it
do you want to be a governor
do you want to be a billionaire
do you want to be a great
father
do you want to be a great pastor do you
want what do you want to be i'm like i'm
freaking
wrestling with this what do you want to
do
like dude the only time i would ever be
a governor is if a piece of you know
what came in trying to bully a freaking
state oh you wouldn't even know what i
would do to that guy
if you decided to take freedoms away
from me you would see a side you've
never seen of this guy
because i'm being asked to be a flag
freaking carrier not because i care
about being whatever that title is i
don't know if that makes sense like i'm
not seeking for the recognition
i'm seeking that's what's needed
freaking let's go
so what you wanna do let's go let's go
do it
if we judge it based on that what's your
score
let me ask you
how easy of a shift of a mindset is this
so let me ask you a person says to you
man i got three appointments tonight
playoffs giannis
why would i be jonas's flight carrier
instead of yours
not freaking giannis's flag carrier i'm
your flat carrier let's run those
appointments
make sense
i have a limited amount of people i'm
going to be a fly carrier to
dream team call number one you're on you
call me i'm your flag carrier
you're an fab number one priority
you're an aligned council vp your
priority you're a team player it's about
company not just about you you you you
you 24 7 everybody knows can't do
nothing with that you still have a
mature
i'm your flag carrier
i'm the flag here in my kids i'm the fly
carrying my wife i'm the flag carry the
bed david family i'm the flag carrier my
niece my nephew i'm the flag here the
home office except david vega needs
something he texts me what do you need
i'm his flight carrier not the other way
around what do you need for me david
just tell me
and freaking david's a beast of a
freaking guy should see the stuff the
guy does at the home office that's a
freaking beast i should get updates in
nine days he gives it to me in four days
now you think i did that i didn't do it
i don't get credit for that
you don't think i appreciate that
when i see mark coming up with ideas and
he goes to tom say yeah but what about
if we do x y z
like mark's thinking that well yeah
mark's like non-stop freaking awesome
when i hear stories about you know
there's different kind of c-suite
executives there's those that want to
rat the ceo out oh you know he's always
like this and this and that and then
there's something i'm not freaking that
guy i'm the one that's here to protect
the ceo and be their advisor it's a
different story this is a guy that i
never flew first class until two years
ago you guys i never paid for a first
class flight until two years ago
and now
barely i'm willing to spend some money
on some stuff because i look at the
money i'm like we put in the gb freaking
that's amazing how much try to put in
the cop i might try to give a 50 000
first two bonus and put fifty thousand
dollars into private jet
absolutely but now the leader's like
well let me ask you you're better off
freaking traveling on a private because
we need you to stay healthy because you
stay in health you bring more value to
the company and it's okay okay good you
sold me fine
fine
i'll buy it that makes sense i get it
it's a different mindset though guys
it's a different mindset when you think
about it from that standpoint you know
what shena matsupal have done to the
company are you kidding me what they've
done to the company
just text me what you need
what do you need
i'm a text or a phone call away
very different mindset when you look at
it from the perspective of what we just
talked about right now the next time you
don't want to pick up on your guys's
phone calls
who's who's flag carrier
got it
you still want everybody your flag here
are you huh
i'm good i'm going to be your flight
carrier that's what i want to do i won't
be pelago's flag here yeah i want to
play one day he's at my funeral he gets
up and he gets emotional he says
this guy changed my life and i want to
see him in tears
to say a handful of men impact me like
this guy this guy's freaking on top of
that list i want to be a flat carrier
for you
all the accolades guys i have more money
right now than i've ever imagined
i'm gonna make a lot of money in my life
it's a very basic philosophy i don't
worry about money i'm a full believer a
lot of reciprocity
money comes so freaking easy it's a joke
because the energy goes out
and when i give it out it comes back 10
20 30 40 50 for like i'm overwhelmed by
it i'm not like worried about the energy
coming back i don't sit there and say
let me see what i can take from jose let
me see what i can take from rodolfo let
me see what i can take from hector what
am i talking about
no
no we're not wired this way
[Music]